a joint investigation by dw and more
than 40 media outlets has revealed how
uber aggressively lobbied governments
and potentially even skirted some laws
as it expanded its ride-sharing service
a trove of leaked documents suggests the
ride-sharing firm hid information from
investigators in the netherlands by
remotely killing internal devices in its
amsterdam office
the report also details the close
relationship between uber and then
french economy minister emmanuel macron
at a time when the company was trying to
avoid french regulations
macron gave the company direct access to
his staff
all right lisa lewis is our
correspondent in paris she joins me for
more on this
lisa i mean in some ways it's not
uncommon for european capitals to mix
very intensively into
their own industries and branches and
even pick favorite companies i mean
paris after all uh owns part of
carmichael renault so help me understand
what is the scandal here when it comes
to uber
well many people here feel it was not
morally acceptable for an economics
minister
to stand by the side of an international
company that they felt was a very
capitalistic and wanted to take down
french labor law that's indeed what some
opposition politicians said today they
said you know he really became
at the time economics minister as he
said he became the lobbyist for a
company that wanted to de-re regular
regulate french labor law and when you
look at it actually the situation of
french taxis and uber at the time was
and still is very different taxi drivers
about they're about 50 000 licenses in
this country and one license can cost up
to hundreds of thousands of years
whereas to become an uber driver
regulations are a lot a lot less strict
and they only have to pay a few hundred
euros and obviously people here were
rebelling against that and said french
prime minister french economics minister
at the time and now president emmanuel
macron should have done more to protect
french jobs and good jobs here because
they taxi drivers have the the
possibility of becoming employees uber
drivers are only self-employed
what have we heard from macron's camp
about what's been reported
iman macron has answered to the reports
he was absolutely contacted by those
carrying out the investigation he said
it was just normal to help some
companies that wanted to disrupt markets
to you know help them make
lift barriers so that they can operate
freely obviously at the time he was part
of a socialist government but even
socialist former president francois
hollande he had pledged to bring down
unemployment he actually said you can
hold me personally responsible in a
political way if unemployment doesn't go
down and that was obviously also what
emma macron was aiming at when he was
cooperating apparently or helping uber
to to develop the market here in france
he was hoping that thousands of jobs
could be created
lisa is the conflict over over uber as
explosive there today as it was years
ago when this was really a big issue
i think it kind of has calmed down
people here have eased into the
situation there's still a judicial
conflict going on actually such as in
other countries
caught here has decided in 2020 that
uber needed to give
it well employees that are not legal
employees at the moment the status of
employees and that they no longer had to
work as independent workers but that
decision still needs to be implemented
and it looks like it's very difficult to
get
either to implement that situation so
the the main focus of the conflict today
is on how these workers how the drivers
of uber can work here in france and what
conditions they would get as a worker
for ebirth
all right dw correspondent lisa lewis in
paris thank you very much
and for more i'm joined now by our
correspondent in brussels christine
mundo christine a high-ranking former eu
official is also implicated in these
leaks how embarrassing is this for the
european union
that's right uh monica a former official
by the name of neely cruz who was
effectively the eu's
digital chief at the time has been
implicated in in in these papers it's
been suggested that during her time
in in her role and in in the months
preceding that
that she was helping uber lobby uh with
senior executives within the european
union as well as in her home country the
netherlands papers show how she for
example was in full support of uber at
some point when the company had
some issues with the authorities in in
the city of brussels in her home country
that she was personally
not just out tweeting in support of uber
for example but also maneuvering behind
the scenes to get the regulators to
quote back off now for her part she
denies any wrongdoing saying that in her
position in her role it was her job to
be talking to to politicians about
companies like uber but if you look at
for example some exchanges in these very
leaks uh between uber executives it
appears that they were aware of the
sensitivity of this relationship that
that they had with this commissioner uh
on number of occasions instructing
colleagues to keep it
confidential so after leaving her post
we must note that she also then went on
to take a job at on uber's advisory
board where she was earning
something to the tune of two hundred
thousand dollars a year
now briefly if you would christine now
that this has been exposed what kind of
repercussions will there be
well transparency groups uh in in the
european union uh these are sort of ngos
are advocating for greater transparency
especially when it comes to what senior
officials do after leaving office the
eu's
ethics laws dictate that when
somebody leaves a position especially of
of that high
a position of a high nature is that that
they're meant to do what's called an
18-month cooling off period in that time
they're not meant to be lobbying
especially uh on topics that they were
previously responsible for in in the
case of nearly cruz it does appear that
it she might have been doing that in
that 18 mil period in that 18 month
period not only that she went on to
secure a job on uber's advisory board
after that so what these groups are
calling for is greater transparency they
say that the eu has egg on its face
because they've been warning
the commission about this because this
is not the first politician to find
herself in this position and they're
calling for greater tightening of the
rules when it comes to uh the ethics
breaches right christine wunder
reporting for us from brussels thank you
so much
you